heavily armed police moving through a
shopping center in Texas after reports
of an active shooter in other parts of
the mall in El Paso shoppers were held
in place while people tried to work out
what was going on then there was what
has become common in America lines of
people being led from the scene of
another mass shooting on a day that
would have been a normal day for someone
to leisurely go shopping turned into one
of the most deadly days in the history
of Texas lives were taken who should
still be with us today 20 innocent
people from El Paso have lost their
lives and more than two dozen more or
injured we as a state unite in support
police have arrested one man a 21 year
old who allegedly posted a racist rant
online on an extremist web site just a
note or so before the shooting but
needless to say the scene is a rific one
unfortunately because of the nature of
the situation the scene will be in play
for a long period unfortunately the
deceased will remain at the scene until
the scene is processed properly for
evidentiary purposes to be gathered for
later prosecution the state of Texas
will be the lead agency or entity
prosecuting this particular individual
it has the Nexus at this point in time
to a hate crime the FBI will be looking
into that with other federal authorities
right now we're looking at potential
capital murder charges for this
individual an emotional Democratic
presidential hopeful Beto
Roark who is from El Paso announced he
was cancer
further campaigning and heading back to
the city and so I just asked for for
everyone's strength for El Paso right
now everyone's resolved to make sure
that this does not continue to happen in
in this country u.s. president Donald
Trump has been informed of the shooting
and promised the city and state any help
required this is the 13th mass shooting
in the United States in just the past
seven days Alan Fisher al Jazeera Rob
Reynolds joins us now from the scene of
the attack the Sun is set the rain has
begun to fall as well Rob on what has
been a very sad and depressing day for
people in El Paso do we know then about
the shooting from here
he has posted something online shooting
more political voices are coming into
that mix president Trump's rhetoric to
violence said that weeks ago which crowd
chanted send we're back
not only but also inspire the moment of
course we will continue to monitor the
situation or Paso with you
Rob as the evening progresses thank you